the d'Ivoire refugee camp near
Thessaloniki Adele al-sharia from the
refugee organization you soar is looking
for clues for so-called push backs
asylum seekers are said to have been
illegally picked up by Greek police and
deported to Turkey yes it's happening
how often the Czech woman with Syrian
roots has been on the trail of these
legal deportations for months these
refugees confirmed of in recent weeks
mainly young men have been taken away
that's why they won't leave the camp out
of fear of deportation the refugee aid
worker knows this is against
international law so if the people are
deported legally okay like we can
discuss about it we can talk about it
but it's by the law while the push backs
are not following the law it's like
completely illegal ostensibly these
private videos are proof of the illegal
push backs these people say the Greek
Coast Guard stranded them on the
lifeboat not far from the Turkish coast
near by the Greek government denies the
accusations in writing they tell that
they comply with international law and
aren't deporting anyone illegally the
city of Thessaloniki in northern Greece
the Greek Turkish border is 300
kilometers away refugees who make it
here can find help and this empty
building on the outskirts of the city
the clinic is organized by the German
nurse Rose Hansen here too
she says police have cracked down the
refugees most recently just a few days
ago Madan Vaughn's in tonight they took
the men away and crammed them into a van
some they walk to a gathering point
where they collected migrants and
refugees they had taken from other
locations as well as amid Kannamma hot
on them we lost them the following day
later we
learned that 30 of these people if there
were only 30 in the end we don't know
had been pushed back to Turkey cell
phone recordings from the clinic window
documents the incident just like nurse
Rose Hanson Adel al-sharia and her
colleague Robert Martin Kovac want to
confirm their suspicions of these
illegal deportations from Greece they
plan to cross the Turkish side of the
border and take us with them the next
morning in Turkey al Sharia and Martin
Kovac set off to inspect the border they
want to see where the refugees were
again forced to cross the evros River
back into Turkey last night at this
point the 200 kilometer long border
river runs behind the rows of trees
deportees land the road as they drive
they tell had their personal belongings
food money and cell phones were all
taken from them in Greece many show
signs of abuse the volunteers provide
them with food and medicine it's quiet
today along this section of the border
Adel volunteers several weeks a year in
this region she can't look away
she won't they come in here
they are no-name there are no one
because nobody knows about them so
whatever happened to them they can die
there and we have no clue that they are
dying there she meets Mohammed from Iraq
in a shelter close to the border in
early June Muhammad and his wife and
children tried to get to Greece at night
with the help of a smuggler
once there they were caught and locked
in a cell with other migrants they were
denied an asylum application and a
lawyer he reports that other refugees
were forced to help push them back
across the river Shahada thommanon
under charge on our own OSHA gentleman
when he escorted us to the shore there
was a rubber booth with two Syrians in
it two rules across there were ten of us
they told us we don't even want to hear
you breathing it was like a secret
operation
I noticed three armed men in civilian
clothes hiding between trees on the
Greek side watching us the entire time
out of binoculars Wow this brutal event
shocked the entire family but they won't
give up hope
al-sharia amarty gavage demand that the
family should at least be heard on the
Greek side of the border next time they
cross after all it's their right
you